[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Вогонь! Приготувались!
Три, чотири!
♪ [Грають на музичних інструментах] ♪
[Наддніпрянщина
Жашків]
♪ [Грають на музичних інструментах] ♪
Отак!
Так, добре! Інструменти покладіть,
квартет залишається.
Всі вийшли сюди
або в коридор.
Ансамблем гармоністів
я керую 27 з половиною років.
Коли я починав у 1991 році,
то мені крутили пальцем біля скроні.
За 27 років школу колективної гри
пройшло більше 250 дітей.
[Іван Сухий
Засновник музею гармоніки]
Я розумів, що тільки грати — це мало,
треба багатосторонньо
розповідати про це, дивитися.
І я збирав матеріал.
Було зібрано стільки матеріалу,
що мені адміністрація запропонувала
відкрити музейну кімнату.
І ота кімната (ця була загороджена)
була музейною кімнатою.
♪ [Грають на музичних інструментах] ♪
Ось чобіток.
Колись дивились по телевізору:
грали на таких інструментах.
А дочка маленька була:
«Тату, можеш зробити такий інструмент?»
То я такий зробив.
Це найперший
із саморобних інструментів.
Дев'ятнадцять гармошок,
кожна з яких має інший звук,
Я додав ще двадцяту,
бо мені не вистачало, і вони грають так.
♪ [Грає на музичних інструментах] ♪
Це зібрані всі гармошки, які є,
щоб показати нащадкам, які були гармоніки,
хоч у одному екземплярі.
Ті, що з медалями — це ті, що були на війні.
Вони всі, бачите, трьохрядні:
австрійські, німецькі.
Трофейні гармошки привозили,
і грали на них.
Післявоєнні народні артисти, музиканти
майже всі починали з гармошки.
Гарбакорд — гармонь, баян, акордеон.
Таке чудо.
До цього я вів оркестр народних
російських інструментів.
Весь час мені хотілося гармошку
вести, і я таке запровадив.
Коли я навчив одного хлопчика грати на гармошці,
то швидко ідеї поширилися,
і вже восьмеро хлопців навчилися.
Я зробив барабан (мені батько допоміг)
і прийшов виклик на міжреспубліканський
дитячий фестиваль у Хмельницьку.
Мене директор викликав, каже:
«Що ти можеш туди повезти?»
А якраз у мене цей оркестр і гармоністи.
Я взяв гармоністів від'єднав,
поставив барабан,
і вийшов своєрідний такий ансамбль.
Ми поїхали і стали
дипломантами цього конкурсу.
Така цікава річ, що наступного року ми поїхали, підготувавшись уже сильніше,
сподіваючись на якесь призове місце.
Ми приїхали, але нічого не зайняли,
і нас навіть не відзначили.
Коли я прийшов до членів журі і кажу:
«Того року ми слабкіше грали, і стали дипломантами, а цього року — нічого».
А вони кажуть:
«У нас гармошки нема і не було в Україні».
Мені було неприємно, що сказали,
що немає такого народного інструменту.
З такою зверхністю до нього.
І я відтоді, з 1991 року, я не грав
жодної російської пісні на гармошці.
Все українське.
І ми, слава богу, працюємо вже
27 з половиною років.
♪ [Грає на гармошці] ♪
Отак звучить цей інструмент.
Ну самі його придумали.
Так, Вікторе Івановичу,
їдемо дванадцятеро чи більше?
— Скільки вас?
— Нас 18.
Так, дітки, сідаємо.
Сідаємо.
Дмитре, іди сюди,
підеш у другий автобус.
Дмитре, також. Іди до тата, будь ласка, сюди.
Все, давай, щасливо!
Зустрічаємось там.
Далі, далі. Так. Хто ще?
Так. Захаре, ти сидиш?
А мама твоя де?
Вона їде в іншому автобусі.
А, там їде? Щось я її не побачив.
Мама не любить бути видимою.
Не любить бути? Вона в тебе невидима, так?
Ага.
У мене є три хлопці, які є лауреатами:
один — трьох міжнародних конкурсів,
а ті два — п'яти міжнародних конкурсів.
І один із них — Паша Врочинський — учасник телешоу «Україна має талант. Діти».
Отримали такі грамоти вони, кожен із них.
Це Асоціація гармоністів нагородила
такою грамотою кожного.
Після цього вони повинні отримати нагрудний знак «Заслужений гармоніст України».
Ми об'їздили 12 країн Європи.
Два роки тому я рахував кілометраж:
чотири рази навколо екватора.
Будь ласка, всі до мене.
— Друзі, всі зібралися?
— Так.
Дмитро ще один іде, ще один Дмитро.
Допоможи йому.
Пішли.
Я не боюся, що вони стануть пихатими,
я не дам цьому статися.
У мене всі діти працьовиті.
Вони повинні знати,
що сьогодні вони досягли,
а завтра — прокинулися і
починають все з самого початку,
або продовжують те, що вміють.
Тоді вони не загордяться.
Не можна, треба дітей виховувати.
Вони повинні пишатися тим, що вони вміють,
але це треба навчитися
пишатися тим, що вмієш.
Це мікрофон, бачиш, останній?
А ти за ним будеш стояти.
Тільки дивися хто, як стоїть. Дивись як Шевченко буде стояти, Діана, і ти там будеш стояти.
«Мантру» грати не будемо.
«Павук», «Пірат», «Європа», «Ой, при лужку», «Лаванда»...
Знаєте, кажуть: «О, в музичній школі діти не хочуть на баян ходити,
діти не хочуть на акордеон ходити,
тільки на піаніно, скрипку, гітару».
Не знаю, у нас у Жашкові є на баян
та акордеон багато охочих,
а у мене — і на гармошку.
Цукерками загнати теж не можу,
треба шукати таке, щоб їм було цікаво.
Робимо усілякі інструменти.
Вареники, наприклад.
Або такі вареники.
Теж застосовуємо, грають.
Ось такий — ексклюзивний.
Гармоністи, вірніше, музиканти, що починали свій творчий шлях із гармошки,
коли стають професійними музикантами,
вони зверхньо дивляться на те,
із чого вони починали —
із тої гармошки.
І така трохи розбіжність виходить.
Я захищаю гармоніку і вважаю,
що вона має право на життя.
Ближче, ближче всі! І три, чотири!
♪ [Грають на музичних інструментах] ♪
Ото як я у селі чув оту гармошку,
я хотів навчитися,
просто хотів навчитися.
Приїхали в Жашків —
пішов у музичну школу на третій день.
Всі шість років займався і знав,
що я йду в музичне училище і нікуди далі.
Таке в мене було відчуття, мені це дуже подобалося.
І до цих пір я люблю цю роботу.
Діти мене не дратують.
У кожного свій характер,
з ним треба боротися.
Але діти щирі у власних ставленнях.
Які вони є, така людина і є.
І мені це подобається.
41-й рік я працюю в музичній школі.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажер
Павло Пашко]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]